[Music]
and shady practice news shady [ __ ]
submitted by victor from virginia hello
tobacco farmer guy a doctor allegedly
borrowed 300k from a patient and Dan
diagnosed her with dementia oh because
he's like what are you talking no one
would ever loan that much money if they
didn't have to that's crazy man cuz when
I think of doctors I think of them as
like really good people like pastors and
stuff and it is regular tea I know but
like they take the Socratic Olsson [ __ ]
Hippocratic oath or whatever [ __ ] I
just want to know who's giving 300k like
yeah you could just give it back after
that's true that's true I want to meet
that person well doctor I mean they
probably manipulated or like like you'd
someone you trust you know if you ever
like a doctor patient trust and I still
would be like no good borrow money from
you that's [ __ ] weird right that's a
lot of money that's a lot of Sh money
look I grabbed your balls let me borrow
three hundred thousand what do you need
it for what are you doing paying off
student loan debt this lady old cuz I
can see why so this doctor in this
patient they've been friends for over 25
years
Oh personal friend and they were a
co-worker and it's also their
doctor-patient relationship and so the
doctor she is 79 years old the doctor
and the doctor 79 yeah and she
apparently borrowed three hundred
thousand dollars from three hundred
thousand three hundred thousand
Herman said like why are you still
working at 79 damn you know alright we
got a couple years left
what so no not yet so she borrowed three
hundred thousand dollars twenty years
ago because her clinic was like failing
and so this patient and friend Bart let
her borrow that money and Ebola I know
right so then the doctor claims that
she's been making payments all these
years to repay her and that the patient
just started having signs of dementia so
that's why she diagnosed her with
dementia but then the patient's like nah
like you never paid me like you know you
just diagnosed me this just so you can
get out of the debt I mean can she know
she's like I've been paying cash I know
she's like no you're tripping I've been
paying you that's some [ __ ] up [ __ ] up
happening was that this doctor retired
her license
just like conveniently you know just I
don't know where so right I think to
make things fair she should be her
servant for the rest of her life which
is like what five years
24-hour servant so you could wake up at
3:00 a.m. be like I want you to go to
the market and make me some steak cuz
then later on there was a psychologist
that assessed the patient and found that
there was no indication of dementia and
that the doctor didn't have like a
second opinion or like didn't perform
any of the tests is she supposed to
perform what is shady what kind of
doctor would work like you could just
say like oh she has dementia and like as
the person defending yourself you can't
be like wait I need a second opinion
well what happened what she ended up
doing was that this doctor she sent the
dementia diagnosis to the daughter of
the patient and then so the daughter
then like it somehow went on to the bank
where the bank stopped her from
accessing her own
so she just woke up one day and she's
like I need money and they're like nope
you crazy [ __ ] she ruined her life
how do people of friends of my 25 years
do something I have a family member that
got [ __ ] over by someone that they've
been working with for 20 years and
because all of that 20 years they've
been lying
it was family started right they just
started Shady
they've been lying like a lying sack of
[ __ ] you know reminds me of you guys
watch training day yes you know in the
beginning then Zell Washington he goes
through that one dudes house and he's
like i'ma be in the Philippines and then
like you think they're tired right cuz
you're just bringing the rookie there
and then later on he comes back with his
homies cuz he only went there just to
make sure that he still had his money
blast his own home and just to steal his
money yeah I'm like duh hurt my feelings
mm-hmm yeah it sucks I can't even
imagine like knowing someone for 20
years and then getting [ __ ] over yeah
because I think I have a pretty good
judge of character yeah that's some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] maybe the doctor has
dementia and you can probably count on
one hand how many people need to be like
yo this amount of money 300,000 I don't
know if I can count it right like you're
good that was it a lot was it a drop on
that half for that person episode like
oh yeah what if she's like a like a
celebrity doctor and she knows a lot of
people with 300,000 oh yeah no but at
that time is when like her clinic was
falling through hard times and that's
why she needed that money to keep her
clinic going what kind of doctor was she
does it say no she's like a foot doctor
no she's just diagnosed with dementia
sorry it's an internal medicine
specialist what's internal medicine it
sounds like some homeopathic kind of
like this internal medicine just regular
doctor like Family Practice that works
in the internal part of the doctors
business I was thinking organs yeah we
don't know [ __ ] yeah like you know when
they go like oh it's a corporate video
it's only for its internal purposes we
shot so poorly right now
really if anybody has a lab coat on I'm
[ __ ] undressing and letting them do
whatever fix me I don't feel good this
is the cost that you have made you guys
never like get geared up because you you
heard stories and then you're kind of
disappointed that it didn't happen like
what like for example like so in the
military you have to get a physical at
once a year you know and then so you
always hear these stories of like the
doctor grabbing her balls and like
making your coffin stuff it's like you
got a physical you got a check for
something right so much [ __ ] this is
gonna be so weird cuz I get nervous my
balls off the ball size also shrinks up
oh it's a girl it could be I don't know
what the doctors but I'm gonna keep my
nuts loose let them hang and keep them
warm so when they grab up I'm a cough
and then and I was just like getting
like you mentally prepare and then when
I when I saw the doctor she just grabbed
I was at all gonna pull my underwear
down she's like no I just keep it on not
like but I practiced I'm not mentally
prepared for this but then someone she
grabbed me she was oh you don't have to
cough I just need to like exhale a
little bit so it was like way less than
what I thought it was gonna be you know
it's kind of just you know what I heard
mammograms you heard that already so
yeah so a couple of my friends just so
recently and they're like younger I
guess they're like 30 year old moms and
she was so scared because we hear that
they just like smash her boobs right and
she's like I'm so mad that everyone told
me that like it literally just felt like
this like someone grabbed your arm like
like this I give her a mammogram every
day almost no he doesn't
she's like I was scared to get a
mammogram for so long like I don't it's
a machine too that like smashes it yeah
but just like it doesn't smash it though
it just like kind of like get there you
can feel pressure but it's not like she
has really big titties
you have the peanut she does that maybe
the girls that are saying and have
really big titties oh that would be like
yes like maybe that machine is too small
for their big boobies that had hard real
boobs hard real change
[ __ ] I'm sure there's gonna be people in
the comments are like I got a mammogram
I hurts so bad but I'm just saying that
I recently heard that you know what her
it's hot and I don't like it the guy no
pap smear
yes the scrapey thing yeah what's that
okay open you all the way up which
although already is looks like too big
for when they go inside your vagina and
they open it like that
yeah and it's a hole thank you I'm in
there so go like this yeah
why could it be like microwave the metal
or make it more more so you know what
they shouldn't why can't it be like
flesh plus she on the outside so it's
like this is kind of like a dick it's
not a dick at all it's like giant
tweezers in you know what do they do
they gotta get all the OBGYNs they go
like this and then ones their aim to go
like a quakes quick open and then you're
like literally like this like let's say
you can [ __ ] feel your insides being
swab yeah and then they scraped it with
like a mascara brush and it's like the
Bruce Lee
you're like scraping I'm squirmy
renomination it get me to and it's like
deep inside there and though I talk to
you about vacations and stuff to try to
relax you and I'm like Palm Springs you
know what sucks when you're pregnant
they're trying it like you're about to
give like you're in your last trimester
the last month and they want to feel how
much the your cervix has been opening if
it's even open at the door it's been
open that wall that walls gonna get so
squirmy just thing my doctor was like
what six-four six-five you have a big
[ __ ] sausage finger
I swear to God probably this much was in
there but these fingers were still out I
don't know or maybe that's right thing I
felt bad for all often do you have to do
this once a week really that's trimester
it's like every week you get your
[ __ ] [ __ ] opened up every week he
would like just go in Wow
I'm only one day when I went to the
hospital and like he actually made me
bleed after that and wanted cramping
like crazy I didn't get that I'm glad
you passed robear IUD out that's why I
won't do that
dude mean the girls [ __ ] hard it is
dude ever have any of your OBGYNs put
their fingers but I don't know that
standard a proctologist job it's a
different doctor I thought was her guys
for like over 30 but guy OBGYN he would
always put all the weight yes and then
he would check my uterus I guess I don't
know
so he never put his finger but I know
you did
the vagina first and then the butthole
and then I was like I started being like
yeah why do I gotta go my butt too when
people are like they don't go in here
but
happen with friends and Joey like his
tailor his dick maybe he does extra
credit like there's some next-level [ __ ]
that's going on because it was my first
ob/gyn so I'm like this is normal and
then later it's like oh it's not normal
I guess I'm not traumatized because I
thought it was before now you're like go
in the back yeah second one and then
they all set him suck their fingers up
my butt I'd be like what the [ __ ] but it
was it was the first time like all the
way in there's my first time tell her
that's not normal no I I never talked to
her you should bring that up my mom got
poked in the butt too
maybe it was only you maybe he find you
attractive yeah I think I'm so flattered
oh yeah I didn't know that wasn't normal
or me I never got my butt tampered with
ever I did maybe you all have buck
cancer and I and you don't know my
doctor put up forming the crops I spill
up my butt and then it wake right back
out and he sounds like I don't want to
do that and he's like okay we'll find
something else have you ever had that
thing were you gonna cut in your butt
hole in your butt it's like it's coming
at him right it's a hemorrhoid
hemorrhoids I'm right oh yeah and then
you put the suppository like a like that
right no no girl this video has got me
into deep waters I just get witch hazel
from my toner and I dab that [ __ ] on my
buff and that [ __ ] disappears real work
I had witch hazel after giving birth but
it's really good for toner because you
got a hemorrhoid right through the thing
being was [ __ ] yeah my whole [ __ ]
ain't cut this is one giant hemorrhoid I
got it when I when I did too much
protein not in a fiber and not enough
when you eat so much yeah it's like you
you get like a hard [ __ ] that's what
happened and yet your insight just
bursts out or maybe was too much blood
fingering
[ __ ] maybe dude it's your own though
[Music]